from schools, from apartment buildings.
Hamas fighters are popping underground
every Hamas tunnel. I don't know if
you've been on Gaza, Pierce. No, you
know why? I haven't been in
Gaza. Hang on. This is where it gets
interesting, guys. I really wanted you
guys to pay attention here. Yeah, cuz I
was I was quite surprised. I was quite
shocked, actually. Yeah. Here we go.
So, right in the
I am a Rever and I was taught how to
pray Salah. That means every single time
I pray, the person who told me gets the
reward. five times a day from fud to
Isa. If you want to support someone like
me in learning salah, then sponsor 10
people for just £100 this Ramadan.
Remember the prophet peace be upon him
said charity does not decrease wealth.
Click the button and donate
now.
Asalama brothers and sisters and dear
friends inshallah. So Pierers Morgan,
has he changed? Has he repented? Has he
changed his ways? And is he pro
Palestinian now? Well, it doesn't matter
because even if he is or not, it doesn't
mean nothing because we are not going to
forget what he done and how he was
supporting this genocide. And now that
his tone is changed after thousands
53,000 plus people dying after that now
he wants to change it's too little too
late my friend. However though you
pushing them finally we're going to make
take an advantage of that in so here's
the interview Pierers Morgan had with
one of their dirt bag Israeli Zionists
as you can see inshallah and let's see
what justification he had. I mean surely
they have to come with something new and
let's see how Pierers Morgan he's
actually made it very clear to the
Israeli official that he wants to enter
Gaza but let's see what's his reason
what's stopping him here's a video a
scale of terror attack we have rarely
seen in modern times of course Israel
had to respond of course it was going to
respond with force Hamas knew that
everybody knew that and the question I
kept asking for the first few weeks and
months was well what is a proportionate
response I didn't know the answer I
genuinely did not know the answer to
what was a proportionate response but
what I feel now is that whatever the
answer this P did you do the same thing
when it when Russia was attacking
Ukraine did you say let's assess and see
I don't know what is a proportional
response I don't know you didn't you
hypocrite and lowkey called you out and
you was called out day in day out and
you persisted and carried on but let's
carry on this has gone way beyond a
proportionate response and that there
are clearly people in the Netanyahu
government perhaps including him who
just want to just keep pounding away
here because they don't really have any
plan for what happens when they stop
pounding uh in Netanyahu whose case he
faces corruption uh trials when he comes
out of this war which is no incentive to
end a war by any yard stick. So you one
thing that you see brothers and sisters
with Pers Morgan is that a proportion
like now he's outraged. You know what it
took like if it's Ukrainian civilians it
only takes one or two or three four
deaths and then it becomes a whole wild
like you know this is disproportionate
response like the journalist was saying
you know this is something that belongs
to the Middle East you know not for the
blonde hair blue-eyed individuals. Yeah
you can see but with the gins with the
Muslims the death toll has to be huge
for it to have the same response. So
imagine two free Ukrainians and 53,000
Palestinians is when they start to say,
"Okay, we need to question it."
Hypocrisy. Um but more importantly, it's
clear from all the intelligence the
Americans have been receiving and all
the reports we've been seeing, there's
no real evidence that that Hamas has
been neutralized at all with this
relentless bombardment. Um we've now had
six times the tonnage of of bombs that
you saw in Nagasaki and Hiroshima
combined. I mean, let's just uh go and
to that point in so has Hamas being
destroyed? No. Let's look at some
articles some you know uh some of them
what they have been saying inshallah. So
brother bro sisters um BBC not BBC sorry
Middle East and I uh US says Hamas has
replaced almost all his killed fighters.
The mirror Hamas fighters are on the
rise and still powerful force in Gaza.
Yes. Uh the times of Israel Hamas has
added up to 15,000 fighters since the
start of the war. Yes. Um, and we got
the list going on. The Jerusalem Post,
Hamas recruiting more terrorists in
Gaza, uh, stripped to combat. So, as you
can see, brothers and sisters, uh,
Israel has been losing the war on all
grounds. Uh, on a space which is, I
think, a third the size of those two
cities. Uh, and where have we got? We've
got to a place where Hamas clearly still
uh are there. They're clearly still
holding these hostages and Israel can't
get them to release them. um which
suggests to me that a mass's power base
is still pretty much intact or that
process would have happened by now. And
I'm not I don't see any endgame or plan
here other than increasingly it seems
that there are people on that government
who just want to get rid of all the
Palestinians who want to just take over
Gaza and that will be it. And that is
actually the very genocide that so many
on the pro-Israeli side keep recoiling
at hearing that word because they say
it's not genocide. Well, if you get rid
of a whole people based on their
ethnicity from an expansive land that is
theirs where they've been living, what
else do you call it? So, I got angry and
then everyone got angry at me because
everyone gets angry about everything you
ever say about this. Finally. Finally,
finally. I mean, he did not say this is
a genocide. He said, "What else do you
call it?" And can you imagine? He did
not say it is a gen. He said, "What else
can you call it?" You can't make this
stuff up, man. You can't like the It's
like a phobia. But when it comes to
Russia and Ukraine, instantly hypocrisy.
is a proportional response to 1,200
people being slaughtered, raped, babies
being burnt, 250 people which have been
taken captive as hostages. What utter
nonsense and rubbish. We know very
clearly with the Hannibal directive that
is this this came out by the IDF
soldiers themselves. Yes. They've come
out and they have said they themselves
the 1200 that were killed. Yes. Okay.
They're taken out to the the Hamas
fights or whatever. It was done by the
fighters. There's people on the ground
who who loved ones died. whatever this
they said clearly it it was
indiscriminate firing from the Israelis
and they have this handable directive in
their in their protocol. So this thing
of the the the the graping and the and
the babies etc. It's they are still
repeating the same this is how shameless
they are. They are still doing this. We
condemn any kind of attack done towards
any innocents. The point is why spew
lies? The whole world has seen it is 57
of which are still in the Gaza tunnels.
I'll tell you I think that the word is a
smokeokc screen. Kamas went after
civilians. And you're asking me what's
the proportional response. Israel's
response has been never to go after
civilian only to go after kamas
terrorists. I've been in Gaza. I've been
in Gaza four different times. They
killed tens of thousands of civilians.
And when you're in Gaza, they kill on
the ground in Gaza. What you see, just
one second. What you see when you're on
Gaza is you're being fired on from
parks, from schools, from apartment
buildings. Hamas fighters are popping
underground every Hamas tunnel. I don't
know if you've been on Gaza, Pierce. No.
You know why? Gaz. Hang on. Hang on.
This is where it gets interesting, guys.
I really want you guys to pay attention
here. Yeah, cuz I was I was quite
surprised. I was quite shocked actually.
Yeah. Here we go. So, um this is where I
mean this Pierce Morgan, the
progenocidal maniac himself. Yeah. He's
don't It appears you're not going to get
away with thinking by just talking about
this and now making some valid points.
You are not proistent ever in history.
It's going to go you're going to go down
as a person who was pro genocide. You
ask a question. You can go into million
people that have But here's the key
point, Doran. International journalists
have not been allowed into Gaza to
independently verify any of this. That's
been another massive problem I've had
with this. If Israel has nothing to
hide, they should let you hang on. Hang
on. Let me finish. Hang
on. Let me finish my question. Have you
had you ever You had 20 years to go to
Gaza. Let me finish my question. If all
of a sudden you want to watch I'm going
to finish my question whether you let me
or not. Okay. And my question is this.
If Israel has nothing to hide, why are
they not letting international
journalists go in? Simple question. Very
valid. If they have nothing to hide,
Israel is killed more journalists than
any war. Yes. Why are they afraid? And
peers, the dirt bag, is a dirt bag. I'm
not giving any credit. You ask a very
question. Yes. Why are you refusing to
let journalists in? Why? Let's see what
this Israeli Zionist dirtback has to
say. Tell me, why don't they let them
all in so that what you're telling us
can actually be independently verified?
Pierce, Israel is trying to deal with a
terrorist regime that is popping out of
tunnels, popping out of buildings, is
everywhere and you want us to unleash a
flood of reporters into the area. When a
Hamas reporter was killed because he was
Hamas, the entire world media blamed
Israel for killing a reporter and he was
a member of Hamas, a verified number of
Hamas that filmed himself as part of
October 7th. So you want us to unleash
the international media to happen right
now. One second.
Pier ask me about a Pierce has
intelligence now. I mean, look, cuz he's
stating the obvious now. He's like, I'm
like, you think I'm stupid now? Yeah,
you've been stupid for a long time, P.
You've been a very stupid man. You have.
Yes. Now, he's saying, "Don't he's
basically offended." P saying, "Are you
telling me? You trying to tell me that
you're not letting us journalists in
there?" P saying he wants to go there.
You're not letting us in because you
care about our wellbeing. You can see
through, right? Why can't you see
through the genocide? You fool.
Questions while I'm speaking. Don't
insult my intelligence. Israel is not
banning international media. I'm just
trying to provide an answer for this. I
feel like I have an opportunity to
actually answer. You're banning us out
of concern for our safety. You're
banning us because you don't want the
international media to witness what
you're doing on the ground for reasons
that I don't know. Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hold on a second. Look at He made a
valid point and then he shoot himself in
the foot. You're not letting us in there
because you don't want us to see what
you're doing, which means there's a
genocide going on. They're hiding it.
And then he follows the sentence up with
um he follow up with saying that oh for
I don't know for what reason you are you
are you stupid? I don't I'm I'm trying
to understand. You just explained why
they're not letting journalists in
because they're committing a genocide
and they don't want you to witness that
and tell the whole world which the whole
world is already seeing. But then Peters
goes goes on to say, "Oh, and I don't
know why you're not letting us in. You
just said it with your own mouth." Like,
are you that are you that the bias that
subconsciously your tongue is just
speaking for you. It's just exposing
you. You can't make this stuff up. But
the best way to remove any suspicion
about what you're doing is to let the
international media in. They will make
their own risk assessment. It will be
down to their security teams as it is in
any war zone. But the idea that somehow
Gaza should be the only war zone in the
world where you don't let international
journalists go and operate and do their
job and you can do that Israel because
you basically control all the access to
Gaza, I'm afraid is for the birds. You
should just let the media in. Then
everything you're saying can be verified
as true or untrue. And the fact that
Israel won't allow it is sticking in my
gullet. And when it's when it's
pretended to be out of some quaint
concern for my personal safety, I'm
afraid it's laughable.
Yeah, more journalists reporters to Gaza
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
times. I myself have taken reporters
into Gaza in armored vehicles, let them
walk around Palestinians on Gaza, take
pictures with their phones every single
day. All you have to do is look at
Telegram, look at X, look at every
single social media channel. If you
think that the suffering of Gazans is
not displayed, you're wrong. What is not
being presented, and this lies at the
very source of your question, is why is
there so much suffering in Gaza? We have
brought 1.8 million tons of food into
Gaza. is a ton of food. 2,000 pounds of
food per person in Gaza. Why? Why are
there people in Gaza that are hungry
right now is because all that food that
goes into Gaza is taken by UNRA, all the
international agencies that fill their
coffers with that food by Hamas who
steals that food from the Gazin people.
And now that Israel actually has a plan
to go into Gaza, take over the Gaza
Strip, enable very clear distribution
points. You should be cheering Pierce.
everyone in the I don't cheer an 11week
blockade of food
to destroy and should be able to bring
the food to the people who need it. But
instead what you are doing and what Jake
is doing is you are
perpetual. Did you not see Did you not
see OD? Do you know who that is? Jake,
who's Odabby? Do you know OD Ra? Did you
speak about Oda Jen? I didn't see him on
your social media. odor here about the
fact I don't know what this guy is
talking about but here Jenk called him
out for what it is and here he
absolutely humiliates him that he is
actually starving people for god knows
11 plus months they are collectively
punishing everyone in Gaza and the whole
world can see and they are doing nothing
they are doing nothing about it
terrorist people in Gaza are the ones
who are torturing the Gaza people 10,000
people came to his funeral
3 million people right now. His parents
received his body around his neck and
his underwear and all of those people,
five were killed and dozens and dozens
of people have gone the worst terrorist
decide to keep Hamas in power and the
reason is is you've never been on the
ground. You're going to talk over
everyone else. talk over you. You start
more people than anyone else in the
world. Don't talk over each other
because no one can hear it. Israeli
propaganda and I'm sick of it. Get him
to shut up for a second and let other
people talk. All they do is Israeli
propaganda. It is a fact that they are
starving the children of Gaza right now.
It is a fact that they have killed over
53,000 people. And he says, "Oh, 1200 is
terrible." He it is terrible what Hamas
did on October 7th. But to say that,200
people killed
children against the government.
thousand people killed are not terrible
every
terrible regime propaganda. You are the
enemy. You are the enemy of the Gazan
people. You are the enemy of America.
You are the enemy of America. Okay? You
got to fight Iraq. You fight. You've
taken you starve children to death. You
are the worst terrorist of my lifetime.
Brothers and sisters, in a nutshell, the
biggest monsters and like Jen said, the
biggest terrorists are these guys. And
alhamdulillah, the whole world, the
entire world has woken up to their
reality and the game is up for Zionism
and Israel. It's up. This is the the the
beginning uh of the end of Israel. The
whole world has seen what they're about.
They've showed that in in in no nowhere
in history have we ever seen in HD
broadcast in 4K a genocide happening.
Nowhere. Yes. And this is the first time
in history and it is so so crazy that
people these individuals who themselves
their forefathers went through such
things under the uh the regime of Hitler
and their forefathers went through this
and for them to do the same thing to the
Palestinians who opened their arms to
them when they were going through this
and have no remorse and of course we
can't put every Jewish person under
this. Of course not. This is this would
be absolutely unfair. There's so many
Jewish people protesting in in Israel.
There are so many uh of them protesting
on the streets here. I know myself of so
many who hate the Israeli government and
what Israel is doing. So the point is
that you cannot make this up and this is
going to go down in history history. And
are we going to learn a lesson from it?
We don't know. But may Allah subhana wa
ta'ala bring relief to the brothers and
sisters in Gaza. I cannot put into words
how traumatizing it is as a father
myself to see my kids starving and I
cannot even give them food. Wah I ask
Allah subhana wa ta'ala to deal with
them. May Allah subhanaa tala deal with
them and may Allah allow us to see that
day. Wallah it is the beginning of the
end of Israel and may Allah subhanaa
tala allow me to see that day before I
die inshallah in this life or in the
hereafter brothers and sisters keep them
in your duas inshallah. Till next time,
asalam
allayikum and Pers Morgan, don't think
the valid points that you made here in
this video rid of that responsibility.
You are going to be you're going to go
down in history as a progenocidal maniac
reporter yourself. Yes, even if you went
to Gaza and saw what those people are
going, you would still you would still
probably blame
them. to lie with her cat.